-Guys, a lot of people are
talking about
schools resuming
in-person learning soon,
and in fact, President Biden
said this week
that he's aiming for all schools
to reopen in the fall.
Now, there's a lot to know about
schools reopening,
but also a lot of misinformation
out there,
which means it's time for,
Fact vs. Fiction.
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Fact vs. Fiction ♪
-Now, let's get started.
First up, fact -- many teachers
have an exciting new curriculum
planned.
Guys...
-Come on.
-That is a fact, guys.
Unbelievable.
[ Laughs ]
Fiction -- most of it will be
spent "unteaching"
what dad taught during
homeschool.
Next up, fact -- if visitors
are permitted in schools,
they should wear a mask.
Fiction -- if visitors
don't have a mask,
they'll have to wear
the mascot head.
That's not true.
-That's not?
-No.
-It's the fiction.
-Here's another fact --
many high schoolers will
be returning
to school just in time for
graduation season.
Fiction -- they've all been
wearing robes
for the past 14 months
anyway.
Well, that's --
That could be a fact.
Next up, we have fact --
it's unclear how many students
are currently being taught
virtually.
Fiction -- it's unclear how many
students are currently
playing Minecraft while
pretending to
be taught virtually.
Next up, we have fact --
there are many students
who still aren't vaccinated.
Fiction -- there are many
students whom
still aren't vaccinated.
And finally, fact --
teachers should know
all the CDC guidelines.
Also a fact -- the CDC
guidelines should include
giving teachers
a million dollars
and a paid booze cruise
for everything they've done
this past year.
That is all the time we have for
Fact vs. Fiction.